with the people that left there were
people that also remained and these were
people who would like once a month linda
i know you're taking time up for
yourself i respect your your thing what
you're doing just letting you know that
i'm i'm sending you love
so once i was ready to go back and
be on socials and be around people
those small group of people i'll say
about 10 to 15 were the people that i
kept really close to me because they
understood my boundaries they understood
what i was doing and interestingly
enough they were all kind of like
working on themselves as well 10 to 15
people yeah that's a lot so so how many
i know you want to go into the 98 how
many was that how many people was that
so that was extended family because i
needed to focus myself people on social
media that i don't know because there
was a lot of things that i used to do on
socials people hit me up in the dms and
it was too overwhelming for me on
twitter and on instagram i was like i
can't do this i can't deal with this
anymore
so how many people was that
do you want to go and look on my socials
both twitter and instagram then you can
work outfield what did you used to do
sorry i apologize i need to know okay so
between 20
2012 to 2016 i ran my own publishing
company
produced four magazines glossy titles
everything independently myself and my
partner at the time
left that
got into the workforce and everything
and then i've always done things to do
with like podcasting like i'm here now
today
or like filming i used to do actor stuff
like extras like i was in holby city for
a bit like as an extra i've always done
creative things so along the way i've
met tons of people who remember me or
remember my interactions those are the
bulk of the people who are on my socials
and support me or whatever so yeah
so and those are the people that were so
toxic you you cut them off
no i told you about a toxic relationship
last year that i cut off so therefore i
decided to cut off 98 of people okay
there's two different including people
like this right which would be the
people you meet now those were the
people on my socials that i felt were
quite overwhelming because i didn't want
to always respond to their dms and at
that point boundaries were a bit shaky
for me
okay
sorry
i've got something to say okay
do you just feel like you just wanted
space yes because i felt i couldn't
like i couldn't bloody breathe
yeah i think the short of it is
you just wanted space yeah you wanted
time for you yeah you didn't want to
really be dealing with
a lot of people or be so you had
selective few people that you could deal
with yeah
and other than that you just wanted your
space yeah i think it's more that like
sometimes we just need space like
not every day you want to talk to people
now of course especially from a massive
fan not every day you wanna not every
day we wanna be happy sometimes we wanna
get up we're pissed off
did someone say that you can't you can't
fully you said you can't fully heal
right or something along the lines or am
i reaching yeah someone said that cool
no i said sometimes you probably can't
fully heal all right cool so do the
training but there's still tiny little
elements of you that are still gonna
have have you ever mind you yeah
obviously i'm guessing most of us have
heard that saying if it's not a blessing
it's a lesson right
cool so for me healing is like when you
can go through a situation and be like
it's not affecting me no more i've
learned it's not like because i get that
what baggage is like for example if
someone broke your trust in a previous
relationship
you're gonna move that you might move
that to another relationship but it's
how you move it there's a difference
you're paranoid now
which you didn't get the blessing you
know i mean i mean you didn't get the
lesson out of that or you can be a bit
cautious which is a normal reaction so i
feel like you can heal in it it's just
about
how you deal with it how you deal with
it giving it enough time i know enough
people that get out of a toxic
relationship give it a month in another
relationship and you're like what are
you doing you're still dealing with your
problems that's because they don't know
how to
stay single like some people they they
they have these strong needs to be in a
relationship to fulfill that void that
they feel so maybe you can heal properly
just a lot of people don't do it the
right way yeah exactly
i can't articulate why but when i hear
people talk about healing it just sounds
like nonsense
and i can't i can't articulate why do
you know what i get what you mean but i
can't it's so personal but it doesn't
look yeah it's about perception and i
get what you mean though i do it's just
like it just sounds like a huge change
like
one person one person was alone for six
months one person went on a trip one
person
what do you mean
from a man's perspective we don't really
care about hearing about no he no but it
depends though deep like if you're
dealing with someone already they say
they don't know when that's talking
about no but let's say they're going to
hill though
that's a big red flag you get me and
i'll find a thing that's healed already
why'd you want to be out here putting
plasters on people all the time
so
because because i'm just like even if
you're you cut off 98 of people how does
that make you a better girlfriend in six
months nothing to do with a relationship
it had everything to do with me and how
i felt and for my mental health well i'm
just thinking like from the guy's point
of view
yeah that's not something i'll just run
into a relationship and be like oh
so by the way i'm healing obviously
like that's gonna scare anybody
from what you'd be surprised
but you know what i just realized men
don't say they're healing i've never
heard a man say are we just well that's
because
well no i think i think men like women
kind of dramatize things
like i think we're kind of more dramatic
like it's a bit dramatic to cut off 98
percent of people for six months it went
for me yeah i mean i'm not saying i
don't i don't know you i don't know
what's but i'm just saying like men are
like okay i took that out i'm a move on
yeah yeah
they'll either go and say oh i had a to
heal in my whole face or i had to heal
and cut everybody off or i had to heal
like this this this 90 of the time i do
feel like healing is an excuse or a
cover up for i'm about to go wild right
now which is i mean like that's what
jada that's what jada pink is women yeah
i mean
i mean what did what did jada say on on
the red table talk she said it's a
season of healing and that's like like
that sounds nuts
and what did she do she she screwed uh
her daughter's drug addict friend
friends yeah and she said she was
healing him
yeah she was healing him she wouldn't
even heal
of oh no of course her it's cause
everything but it is about perception
though to an extent and it because it's
like
my healing can be different to
everyone's healing
that's like confusing because a lot of
times girls will use words and like we
can't even agree on what they mean yeah
so it just kind of comes off as like
nonsense to men but it doesn't matter
it matters to you and it makes sense to
you but she means what i'm saying when
you're communicating to other people it
does matter that they can understand you
it's both ways though i feel like like
if you want to let's say you're only
healing to not equal not only your
healing aid to better yourself as an
individual and b to then be ready for
another relationship because be around
others yeah exactly so yeah i get like
in that aspect then it of like yeah
that's nothing to do with this guys
yeah but it's just it's just when we say
healing a lot of times there's no
nothing tangible that anyone could say
you're a better person now than you were
six months ago it's just like oh some
time has passed i didn't talk to people
or oh i went on a vacation or oh i went
i wrote the see what are they called
i would disagree too
i um was in a relationship for quite
some time anyway it didn't work out as
these things sometimes do
and i got really angry and i got really
aggressive at this person and i was
heartbroken and then i had to take a
while for myself to realize
actually a lot of that the red flags
were there but i